uh let's hear from a couple of other
people
um just remember that putting
parentheses in front of your nickname on
discord to get to the top of the list
guarantees you will not speak to me
because that it's just it's just a trick
okay people like oh it's alphabetical
i'll start with parentheses and then
i'll be at the top i don't even look at
those so that's a good way to to not get
on let's go to chris from uh
massachusetts chris welcome
hey david hello
um i don't have much for you today i
guess um
uh have you have any other callers
talked about the roe v wade decision
only all of them
only all of them what about the uh the
leak
yeah well i mean listen uh the leak
summer saying is the most serious thing
that's ever happened worse than the
trump riots the fact that this leaked
three weeks early it's like pearl harbor
yeah i mean uh that in my opinion is
probably one of like i don't know the
lesser consequential factors of this
whole kind of i agree i think that's
unfolding it is a kind of one thing
though is i i've heard people
saying online that you know oh the
leaker is this patriot
and uh we don't really know
why this content was leaked i agree so i
would i would be hesitant to
you know kind of go like take that line
so early because you know there's a
compelling
something that i find compelling is the
idea that you know this was leaked
earlier than the normal uh supreme court
summer
uh publishing of these decisions yeah to
get it into the media cycle
earlier than it would be and farther
away from the midterms so that i can run
through the media cycle uh maybe folks
will forget about it um
before the midterms happen it's very
speculative it's very i mean listen you
could say
oh no they leaked it the day
that the primaries started to have the
maximum effect or you could say what
you're saying which is if you wait it
has more of an effect so by leaking it
instead of waiting until the end of june
now voters can have it in mind for all
of the primaries in may and june i think
you can make the argument either way we
just don't know for me it's like we
found out three weeks earlier that's
that's it it's really not a big part of
the story for me
do you think there's any merit in like
the idea that you know
these leaks you know if they were to
happen again in the future would
influence you know the supreme court
justices and their decisions
i i really don't because i mean i don't
know they're appointed for life and they
have great security it's just hard for
me to imagine that
yeah because it seems like
because of the fact they were appointed
for life i mean how much is public
opinion right uh really influence their
decisions i agree completely yeah i just
i just don't see it
all right thanks david all right my
pleasure there's chris from
massachusetts with some relevant
elements for today's show one of our
sponsors is called privacy privacy is a
totally free service that i've been
using for years privacy lets me create
virtual payment cards with one click and
when i use the virtual card the money is
taken out of my bank account you can
create multiple cards delete them freeze
them set a spending limit on them let's
say i'm signing up for a free trial and
it requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up i can delete that
virtual card so i know i'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video